Nick I think when you get to like I
think when you get to be like a one
percent guy right he's he's top five
percent whatever they've run
multi-million dollar businesses they
probably know a lot of [ __ ] you don't to
be honest unless you're on that same
level but like if I was dating a guy
that's a billionaire or a millionaire I
would trust his judge I'm sorry I have
to remember that that's the one percent
you know how many of us are really going
to touch the one percenter right
combination of your super you're very
and clearly super intelligent but that's
also luck like not everyone is super
intelligent makes it so it's kind of
like oh it's not you're right it's
partially luck but I have not seen many
people make a 20 30-year career without
being somewhat smart and somewhat driven
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like you
know it's like five minutes of fame
right like a year or two years
yeah okay wait
um okay so the next Super Chat so none
of you were taking a spanking from your
significant other I'm not oh yeah
okay
to make this educational and y'all
trying to make it about sex please relax
I told you I was profiting off of all of
your beauty what do you mean I told you
I know I'm pregnant but I know I don't
fit the male gays
yeah yeah what are you talking about
they said okay he keeps saying that and
I'm like I would love to get spanked you
know like she's not going to live
against me or whatever like he says
okay this is the next one next one next
one this show is about to make Pearl
realize those chicks from fresh and fit
are the norm not the outlier the
ratchetness is internal fellas period
sorry guys nothing
um other women's disrespectful to us
sure here okay
it might get get Gabby a mic give me a
minute
I'm gonna get real liberal in this [ __ ]
so you don't want that
um okay so I'm gonna do one last
question to close out the show would you
rather date a guy that's flat broke
but the hot like the finest man you've
ever seen in your life no or super rich
you never have to pay a bill again
but no he's not toxic but
ugly yeah but ugly like he's shorter
than you kind of overweight
date I know Mary Mary you're with one
guy I have met the finest man that I
will ever meet and he was a thug and in
and out of jail and a drug dealer and he
was the sexiest man I've ever met my
life and I would never be with him
because what is he doing with his life
nothing what the drug money looking like
happy medium what's that drug money
looking like not [ __ ] cause he's going
into jail
you're right you're right it's single an
option
none of the above yeah literally like I
don't know that just that just sounds
like a mess I feel like
you know if I could hold my own and I'm
independent I'm probably gonna go with
the attractive person yeah
um but like genuinely attractiveness for
me has to be your personality so
physically yeah if you that's fine you
could go you could go with that like the
personality is included in the
attraction good because I was about to
say if we just talk your face like you
could be really fine but an [ __ ] so
like it's really not going to be worth
it to me if you broke and mean like pick
a struggle but okay so you so you would
pick hot you would pick Rich you get to
pick one hot
Rich
okay okay that's okay
but the bills
myself and what about my kids
generational wealth
[Music]
I personally don't want my kids to ever
have to ask me like can I do this and I
don't want to say no like can I go to
this school can I do this no like it's
with the career that I'm going into like
probably like I'm gonna make 150 000 at
the most like yeah personally
if I'm really looking at like
the big picture that I'm gonna go in the
long run you want to be able to help
your kids that makes
because of my personal experience yeah
okay so so hot rich but whatever I'm
attracted to like no you're you're
attracted to the hot books
I'll hold it down myself
what's your what's your degree and I'm
just curious
events does that does that how much does
that make
you can make up to like 50k like even
more like a lot it depends on what part
of the event you get into that you can
get into hosting a lot of things
marketing PR so if you're at 50k though
that's like what but that's minimum like
there's a lot you can get up to you can
get you can like there's a lot of people
that make up to 100K like a lot right
right it depends
you'd be cool with him being like a
stay-at-home husband to be honest career
woman so yeah okay okay so okay so hot
hot rich
for me
if he has something going for him
because essentially he doesn't not the
hot one
he doesn't honestly I'm gonna be I'm
gonna keep it 100 with you if he doesn't
have nothing going for him I wouldn't
choose either because I'm not about to
you would be by yourself yeah I'm not
about to be with someone that I don't
find a chance
I wouldn't
want to just resort to
being with somebody because they have
money I'm gonna have my own I'm gonna
work hard for my own and have my own but
I don't want to resort to struggling
with somebody because I struggle my
whole life struggling with somebody that
because they're attractive but the the
see for me like that would come at the
cost of not having kids and that like I
couldn't I could not I would I think my
like purpose on this Earth is to be a
mother someday yeah so if I didn't get
to do like I I would pick the hot one
because I have like the sexual
no because I have family money so I
don't need it she said I ain't got money
already not not now but someday so like
for me like I don't have family money
but like I also like but also I'm
Italian I grow up in a culture that like
pop out as many as you can yeah and I
mean I'm not gonna do that yeah like if
I did I would have probably three kids
by now yeah we're only 22. yeah but she
said by now hey man when do your periods
start yeah yeah
like I don't feel like I don't have that
to fall back on so if we're going off
with children like I want to have at
least three at least yeah like so that's
why you pick the rich guy because you'd
have to afford it yeah because like I
also feel like like I'm such a motherly
personality and just in general like I
I've always felt like part of my purpose
on this Earth is to be a mom you know
what I'm gonna switch mine because I
just know if the guy was laying around
the house all the day I would not be
attracted to him no matter yeah he is I
switched my answer
you're still in the same spot shut up
before I say some [ __ ] that I'm gonna
regret oh my gosh
I was gonna say like when it comes to
the person being ugly like if that
includes their personality I'm not going
to be able to withstand that yeah
emotionally yep but if they have a good
personality and they're ugly man I've
been with some ugly [ __ ] before
so you know it's not going to be that
much of a problem because no matter what
like as soon as I see you're a good
person you have a good heart yeah I'm
always going to be attracted to you yeah
exactly exactly
okay well guys